SO PLANNED PARENTHOOD HAS
BEEN IN THE NEWS A LOT
LATELY.
AND IT CAN BE HARD TO KEEP
UP WITH THE BACK STORY.
BEFORE WE GO ANY FURTHER,
HERE'S WHAT YOU MAY HAVE
MISSED.
>> PREVIOUSLY ON AMERICA'S
FRAUGHT RELATIONSHIP WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD, A NEW
UNDERCOVER VIDEO WAS
RELEASED THIS MORNING
>> DEFUND PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
>> BASTARD!
>> TO HARVEST IT'S BRAIN.
>> THERE IS NO PROOF IT HAD
ANYTHING TO DO WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, REPUBLICANS ARE
THREATENING TO SHUT DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> Larry: PRETTY MUCH, GLAD
WE HAD THAT REFRESHER COURSE,
YOU KNOW, I ACTUALLY DIDN'T
REMEMBER A LOT OF THAT.
SUMMER MAY BE OVER BUT THE
GRILLING SEASON IS STILL
GOING STRONG ON CAPITOL
HILL.
>> FIREWORKS ON CAPITOL HILL
AS LAWMAKERS QUESTIONED AND
CLASHED WITH THAT
ORGANIZATION'S PRESIDENT.
CECILE RICHARDS, THEY
QUESTIONED HER ABOUT FIVE
HOURS.
>> FIVE HOURS WHAT IS THERE
TO SAY.
IS ABORTION LEGAL?
>> YES.
>> OKAY.
>> THANK YOU. WHAT TO DO FOR
FOUR HOURS AND 59 MINUTES,
SUDOKU, CANDY CRUSH, A HOBBIT
MOVIE, FIVE HOURS IS A LONG
TIME TO LET THE PRESIDENT OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD SPEAK BUT
NICE THAT THEY GAVE HER SO
MUCH TIME TO GET HER POINT
ACROSS.
>> CONGRESSMEN, LET ME TELL
YOU --
>> NO, NO, NO.
WE DON'T HAVE TIME FOR BIG
NARRATIVES.
MY POINT IS --
>> EVEN THOUGH WE ARE --
>> WE DON'T OWN ANYTHING IN
THOSE COUNTRIES.
WHAT OUR GLOBAL--
>> I HAVE TO KEEP GOING.
GO AHEAD.
>> I'M SORRY.
>> DON'T DO MAMMOGRAMS THERE
IS ONE OR TWO PLACES THAT DO
IT.
>> COULD I ANSWER THE
QUESTION?
>> NO, YOU CAN'T ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
IT'S CALLED A HEARING, NOT A
SPEAKING.
JESUS, LET THE WOMAN SPEAK
FOR CHRIST'S SAKES.
AT LEAST ALLOW HER TO USE
THE WORDS YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO LISTEN TO.
>> I CAN ASSURE YOU I'M NOT
GOING TO BE TOUGH ON YOU BUT
SURELY YOU DON'T EXPECT US
TO BE EASIER ON YOU BECAUSE
YOU'RE A WOMAN.
.
>> Larry: AND SURELY YOU
DON'T EXPECT ME TO BE EASIER
ON YOU BECAUSE YOU'RE AN
ASSHOLE.
(APPLAUSE)
WHAT KIND OF BULL [BLEEP] IS
THIS.
A NASTY ATTITUDE.
NOW OF COURSE, THIS WASN'T
REALLY ABOUT LISTENING AT
ALL.
IT WAS ABOUT THE THEATER OF
IT.
SPECIFICALLY PUTTING ON A
GOOD SHOW FOR AMERICA.
AND LET ME TELL YOU, THIS
TROUPE OF CONGRESSIONAL
PLAYERS, THEY REALLY LIKE TO
HAM IT UP.
>> DO YOU FIT-- DEFEND THE
SALE OF BABY BODY PARTS?
>> NO.
AND I THINK THAT IS REALLY A
TOTAL MISCHARACTERIZATION.
>> Larry: [BLEEP] WHY WOULD
ANYONE WANT TO SELL BABY
BODY PARTS WHEN LEASING IS
SUCH AN ATTRACTIVE OPTION.
RIGHT?
AM I -- AM I WRONG?
COME ON.
BABY BODY PARTS IS ABOUT
LOSE HALF OF THEIR VALUE AS
SOON AS YOU DRIVE THEM OUT
OF THE CLINIC.
COME ON YOU GUYS.
SHOOT THE MESSENGER.
THAT'S A TOUCHY CROWD.
I LOVE THE WAY THEY'RE
TREATING HER LIKE SHE'S SOME
VILLAIN, YOU KNOW, JUST
BECAUSE SHE IS DRESSED LIKE
CLAIRE UNDERWOOD, DOESN'T
MEAN SHE'S EVIL LIKE CLAIRE
UNDERWOOD.
>> FEWER THAN 1 PERCENT OF
OUR HEALTH CENTRES DO ANY,
FACILITATE FETAL TISSUE
DONATION FOR THE PATIENT BUT
>> MY TIME HAS RUN OUT.
I JUST WANT TO SAY, SAY THIS,
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE
APOLOGY YOU OFFERED WAS LIKE
WHAT, SOME CRIMINALS DO.
THEY'RE NOT REALLY SORRY FOR
WHAT THEY'VE DONE.
THEY'RE SORRY THEY GOT
CAUGHT.
>> Larry: YES, THE FLOOR
RECOGNIZES CONGRESSMAN
DUNCAN'S ATTITUDE AS A
[BLEEP] ONE.
AND WOULD LIKE HIM TO YIELD
THE REMAINDER OF HIS TIME.
THANK YOU.
>> ALSO, IF IT PLEASES THE
CHAIR, I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
SUGGEST THAT CONGRESSMAN
DUNCAN GO JUMP UP HIS OWN
BUTT HOLE, THANK YOU.
>> BOOM.
DUNCAN WASN'T THE ONLY ONE
SHOWBOATING.
CHECK OUT REPRESENTATIVE
JASON CHAFFETZ OF UTAH.
>> I NEED TO SHOW THIS LAST
PART.
THIS ONE I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
THAT IS THE REDUCTION IN THE
BREAST EXAMS AND THE RED IS
THE INCREASE IN THE ABORTION.
THAT'S WHAT IS GOING ON IN
YOUR ORGANIZATION.
>> Larry: OKAY, I WANT YOU
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY JUST
SHOWED YOU.
THAT CHART MAKES NO SENSE AT
ALL.
DID YOU SEE, THEY'RE
COMPARING THE DECREASE IN
CANCER SCREENINGS TO THE
INCREASE IN ABORTIONS AS IF
THEY'RE RELATED.
BUT PLANNED PARENTHOOD DID
935,000 CANCER SCREENINGS
COMPARED TO 327,000
ABORTIONSMENT BUT ABORTION
IS LIKE WAY HIGHER ON THE
CHART.
YOU CAN'T JUST MAKE UP HOW
CHARTS WORK.
THAT'S NOT A THING.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: RIGHT?
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
GOOD LORD.
OTHERWISE YOU COULD PROVE
ANYTHING YOU WANT THAT WAY.
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS OF
MOVIES IN THE BEST EXOTIC
MARI GOLD HOTEL FRANCHISE
AND IT CORRELATES TO THE
LOSS OF ARCTIC SEA ICE.
MY GOD, ACCORDING TO THIS
CHART, THE DELIGHTFUL
COMEDIES ABOUT THE ELDERLY
REMEMBERING HOW TO LOVE
AGAIN ARE KILLING OUR PLANET!
I SAID IT BEFORE AND I WILL
SAY IT AGAIN, GODDAMN YOU
DAME JUDI DENCH.
(LAUGHTER)
CAN WE PLEASE, PLEASE,
PLEASE GIVE CECILE RICHARDS
A CHANCE TO ANSWER WITHOUT
SOMEONE INTERRUPTING HER.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT, I WILL
NEED TO SEE A LITTLE MORE
SNOTINESS.
>> WHY DO YOU NEED FEDERAL
DOLLARS, ARE YOU MAKING A
TON OF DOUGH.
>> WE LIKE OTHER MEDICAID
ARE REIMBURSED FOR SERVICES
PROVIDED.
WE DON'T JUST GET A BIG
CHECK FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
>> Larry: OH, WAIT, OH, YOU
GUYS DON'T TAKE THESE?
I DID ALL MY BUSINESS WITH
GIANT CHECKS.
I-- GOD, OKAY, ALL RIGHT
>> I NEVER REMEMBER HOW IT
GOES BACK IN.
NOW LOOK, ALL THIS
GRANDSTANDING AND OVERACTING
ISN'T ABOUT GETTING RID OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
IT'S ABOUT GETTING RID OF
ABORTION.
A LEGAL AND PROTECTED RIGHT
ACCORDING TO THE SUPREME
COURT OF THE UNITED STATES.
SO--
(APPLAUSE)
LDZ I'LL TELL YOU, SO SHORT
OF HIRING ARMED GUARDS TO
STAND OUTSIDE WOMEN'S
VAGINAS
FROM THE '70s, APPARENTLY
WITH THERE'S NOT MUCH
ANTIABORTION ACTIVISTS CAN
DO.
BUT AS LONG AS ABORTIONS ARE
HAPPENING, AND THEY ARE
HAPPENING, DON'T WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WOMEN HAVE A SAFE
PLACE TO HAVE THEM?